I have some actual good news related to the
women's March, which has unfortunately become
very toxic and counterproductive as a movement.
Um, over the last year or so, the women's
march is replacing three inaugural board members
and cofounders who I've talked about before,
three people who have been dogged by endless
problems of uh, a marginalizing people who
aren't the right type of intersectional allegations
of antisemitism, marginalization of Jewish
women who want to be part of the movement.
And I'm talking of course about Bob Bland
to Mika Mallory and Linda Sarsour is our sewer
of course, is now a Bernie Sanders surrogate.
I told you that about a week or two ago, something
that Bernie should be 110% disassociating
himself from maybe this will push him to do
that.
Uh, there will be a new set of 16 board members
coming in, including three Jewish women and
a trans woman and a whole bunch of other people.
Now, to be totally honest, this strikes me
as too little, too late.
Um, I, the, the women's March name at this
point is, uh, quite tarnished the relationships
with historically allied communities like
the Jewish community, one of the forefront
civil rights advocate communities in the United
States.
Historically, it may be irreparably afraid.
I'm not saying I want it to be, I'm saying
it may be.
I'm glad that Mallory blend and Sarsour are
going, bye bye.
But I'm just wondering out loud, not in a
rhetorical sense, but I'm just wondering,
is this an organization that is going to have
a role in the 2020 election because you have
a progressive movement that's more engaged
than ever.
You have new coalitions of all kinds.
That includes a very, very list of groups
that are ready to go and working on the ground.
The women's March has been dogged by these
people.
It's become extremely divisive and to be honest,
this is also, it's almost like too friendly,
a way of cutting ties with absolutely toxic
people.
The three board members have stepped down.
It's unclear whether they were forced or not.
I still seems a little bit soft.
The statement that was put out by the women's
march is completely gushing about the groundbreaking
work and sacrifices towards equal rights.
Unless of course you don't fit the right version
of intersectionality, in which case you're
marginalized.
And it's also unclear how much the people
that remain or are replacing them are fans
of, for example, Louis Farrakhan and the nation
of Islam mill you with which Sarsour and Mallory
at least, and I'm not sure about Bob Bland,
we're affiliated with, I just don't know and
I don't want to be little people when they
make the right decision.
The right decision is that these three have
no business being part of a group that claims
to be about inclusivity and egalitarianism
and all of that.
No question about it.
At the same time, it's hard to see this and
have sort of a renewed enthusiasm for an organization
whose rallies have become sort of secondary
to the internal conflict and the discrediting
of potential and actual a constituent activists
and it is sad because it started with at least
ideas that are really good ideas that I, that
I'm behind.
The upside is that I do see the momentum of
the progressive movement having legs in 2020
that go way beyond the women's March and that's
a great thing.
The women's March at this point is not going
to be central to what happens in 2020.
It's all of the other progressive activism
which is so widespread at this point in time.
And that's a good thing.
We don't want a prominent organization to
progressive activism that functions as a sort
of gatekeeper that says, well, Jewish women,
they're not really intersectional in the way
that we want a, and now the, the question
is, will Bernie Sanders Disavow Linda Sarsour
as a surrogate, a totally divisive character.
She shouldn't be involved with a good progressive
campaign like the one that Bernie is running.
Uh, and by the way, I expected wholly negative
reactions to my segment last week or the week
before saying, Linda Sarsour should not be
a Bernie surrogate.
There was a little bit of that toxic left
that didn't like it, but overwhelmingly positive,
overwhelmingly positive response to that and
that that may have been an area I would have
previously self-censored on.
So that's great.